Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3 is blowing
up movie theaters like rocket and one of
his Moon destroying weapons and there
are plenty of very good reasons for its
deserved success
one of the biggest factors that weighed
on the release of Ant-Man and the WASP
quantumania was the fact that it hit a
wall of negative critical reviews before
it even reached its opening night in
contrast Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3
was buzzing the moment the early
screening started to be clear some
reviews were a mixed bag but that didn't
matter the overwhelming message from
early viewers was simple volume 3 is one
of the mcu's crown jewels the warm early
reception paved the way for viewers to
flock to the cinemas to see if the
critics were right with so much Buzz
over the long-awaited third installment
the strong initial response confirmed
that everyone needed to get to a theater
to see the space spectacle for
themselves
there's one significant external factor
that guaranteed that the third
guardian's film would succeed at the box
office there was very little competition
James Gunn's third and final MCU
installment arrived in cinemas with
Evergreen movies populating screens and
no major tentpole film on the horizon
Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3 came out
on May 5th the Super Mario Brothers
movie came out on April 5th despite
release dates one month apart Super
Mario was still the runner-up at the box
office on quill and Company's opening
weekend look at us we're adorable the
pair was distantly followed by other
less popular options like Evil Dead rise
are you their God it's me Margaret and
newcomer love again other cinematic runs
were also still playing including John
Wick chapter 4 and Dungeons and Dragons
honor among Thieves which goes to show
how slim the options were on the first
weekend of May 2023 and the second place
competition from the still over
performing Mario only brought in 18.6
million dollars less than a sixth of the
galactic-sized total domestic Hall of
Guardians
Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3 came out
in early May right in the middle of
spring but the trailers builds the film
as an early summer blockbuster the truth
is summer Blockbusters don't care about
hard calendar dates warm weather is here
summer break is right around the corner
vacations are on the calendar the summer
movie season has arrived and the third
guardian's installment capitalized on
that fact the argument goes back and
forth about whether the summer box
office is all it's cracked up to be and
the 2023 summer slate is certainly a
mixed bag there are plenty of tentpole
films and Indie Alternatives coming to
theaters in the coming months but the
post-pandemic theatrical slump continues
to dog Cinemas making any summer success
questionable still Guardians 3 managed
to pull some of that summer box office
magic into spring the result was a film
billed as kicking off the supposedly
impending summer swell which certainly
didn't hurt the movie's must-see appeal
the theatrical experience isn't what it
used to be before the pandemic going to
the movies was a common activity
regardless of what movie titles were up
on the Marquee but the entire Pastime
came to a screeching halt in 2020 due to
the pandemic since quarantines and
social distancing requirements have
lifted theaters have had a slow and
painful return to normalcy even then the
new normal for theaters is hardly
reminiscent of the old one packed
auditoriums are rare and only tend to
happen when there is a truly big movie
that will attract an audience Guardians
of the Galaxy vol 3 fits the bill of a
genuine tentpole film in a way that few
others can it's a large-scale story with
A-list talent and glittering special
effects that concludes the story of a
top property in an already wildly
successful Cinematic Universe by
post-pandemic theatrical standards
Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3 was simply
too big to fail
Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3 is worth
watching for the emotional story it
tells but plenty of external factors had
viewers ready to watch it as soon as
possible one of the most prominent of
these was watching James Gunn's MCU swan
song as the veteran director prepares to
reboot Superman as part of his DC
focused future fans were ready to flock
to see his final directorial moments in
Marvel's Universe the emotions were even
higher for fans who remembered Gunn's
sudden dismissal from the franchise back
in 2018 and is even more abrupt rehiring
two years later since Gunn's
reinstatement fans have anxiously waited
to see what he would cook up for his
last Huron the MCU and he didn't
disappoint
back in 2014 the unexpectedly emotional
story of the first Guardians of the
Galaxy captured the hearts of Die Hard
and fair weather fans alike the success
of the first film was so great that it
competed with obvious Blockbusters like
the Avengers and the hearts and minds of
MCU audiences its sequel well less
popular still built on the existing
narrative simultaneously creating more
laughs and greater emotional Stakes we
were always searching for a family
until we found each other
during the extended lull between the
second and third franchise films the
bumbling but heroic group got tangled up
in the infinity Warfare with the
Avengers where they lost Gamora and saw
half of their crew snapped Into Thin Air
they went through even more harrowing
adventures in Avengers end game before
making a brief pit stop in Thor's fourth
franchise film then they set the stage
for volume 3 with the Disney plus
Christmas special released in late 2022
from their spunky Origins to a Christmas
light infused romp on nowhere with Kevin
Bacon this ragtag team of Heroes has
seen it all the fact that their third
Standalone film was heavily billed as
the original group's last outing and the
final chapter of their story made it an
automatic trip to the theater on opening
weekend for countless fans
the MCU is in the midst of a seismic
shift the first three phases of the
Cinematic Universe collectively build as
the infinity Saga officially ended in
the wake of the conflict with Thanos
since then phase 4 struggled to
recapture the magic of the first wave of
Marvel movies new Heroes were introduced
in isolated stories that only
occasionally overlapped with the larger
narrative in addition the use of Disney
plus limited series alongside
full-length feature films disrupted and
accelerated the traditionally slow
build-up of past MCU storytelling Phase
5 has begun with Kang looming and many
crossovers in store yet the transition
from the classic Avengers to a new
roster of Heroes remains shaky that's
why a group like the Guardians of the
Galaxy is so Priceless the team links to
the past and projects into the future a
movie like this one evokes Nostalgia
while also setting up the storylines and
Stakes of future films this isn't just
helpful behind the scenes fans feel it
too the ability to live in the comfort
zone of past franchise experiences while
getting amped for future possibilities
gave volume 3 a dual attraction that is
hard to find in the MCU at the moment
one morbidly fascinating factor that
doubtless Drew many viewers to see
Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3 on opening
weekend was the question of who was
going to die well there are multiple
death scares particularly for Star-Lord
and Rocket by the time the credits roll
no one from the original gang is given
their final Last Words yet the question
of which of the original gang would die
was in the air for months leading up to
the film's release the trailers showed
clips of nebula carrying a limp
Star-Lord rocket is shown surrounded by
white light there's a snapshot of quill
screaming in grief the signs were there
and while they ended up being red
herrings they motivated a lot of viewers
to get off the couch and hightail it to
the nearest big screen before they saw
spoilers online
rocket is one of the original Guardians
of the Galaxy he's been with the team
from the beginning when the crew bumped
into one another on xandar he bonded
with his new family and suffered through
losing them in the blip yet despite his
presence cynical humor and endless
Devotion to his friends we didn't really
know who the mcu's version of Rocket was
or if you want to blow up moons no one's
blowing up moons you just
joy out of everything the promotional
material made it clear that the third
guardian's movie wasn't just a send-off
for the original team but also an homage
to Rocket the Raccoon was an
underdeveloped character that was near
and dear to the director's heart in a
2022 interview with Entertainment Weekly
Gunn explained his motivation for
shining a spotlight on the guardian's
smartest member he said one of the
reasons why I came back to make this
movie was because I felt like I needed
to tell Rocket's story I would have been
very sad not to complete the trilogy for
many reasons but I just feel very
connected to Rocket I feel like nobody
would be able to tell his full story if
it wasn't me Gunn may have a special
affinity for Rocket but there are
millions of fans close behind him
learning the origins of everyone's
favorite trash Panda was too good to
miss
Groot has had one of the most
transformative journeys of any MCU
character while the stoic nature of
groot's race has remained intact
throughout the Arc of his character's
Evolution the rest of him has changed
every time we've seen him
[Music]
the original Groot from Guardians of the
Galaxy went down in a self-sacrificing
ball of arboreal Glory as the team saved
xandar from an infinity stone wielding
Rhone in the accuser by the end of the
film an offshoot of the hero was growing
in a planter in volume 2 Baby Groot is
dancing around with toddler-like
innocence Infinity War features a
teenage Groot obsessed with himself and
uninterested in helping unless he has to
by the Guardians of the Galaxy holiday
special grouped is looking all grown up
one of the small yet significant draws
of a third Guardians of the Galaxy flake
was the fact that we could see where
Groot is in his ever-growing state it
turns out that we get two iterations for
the price of one initially Groot is in
his young adult phase and he remains
that way for the bulk of the movie
however in one of the end credit scenes
we're treated to a super-sized version
of the character whether he's a
happy-go-lucky sapling or a living tree
gouging where the character is during
his life cycle has become a fun
Revelation with each guardian's
appearances
looking back Thanos was a pretty
incredible MCU antagonist building up a
multi-movie villain and delivering a
satisfying payoff is hard one-off
villains often outshine them especially
with good writing and execution past big
bads like Michael B Jordan's killmonger
and Kate blanchett's hella exemplify
this and so does Chuck Woody ouuuji's
High evolutionary and Guardians of the
Galaxy Vol 3. the high evolutionary is a
detached and lofty villain who
fascinates and horrifies all at once
while less sympathetic than other
antagonists the character is frightening
in a cold and rational way that makes
him the stuff of nightmares I'm not
trying to conquer the universe I'm
perfecting it iwoji brings the high
evolutionary to life in an incredibly
believable way with a performance that
ranks amongst the best that the MCU has
given us in years the high evolutionary
may go down with his planet-sized ship
but he made a big impact in what just
might be his only MCU appearance
Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3 may seem
like a blast from the past but it
technically belongs to Phase 5 of the
MCU it fits squarely in the middle of
the current Mega narrative Arc the
Multiverse Saga true the third film in
the series doesn't have much to do with
traversing multiple Dimensions but It
prepares the ground for the increasingly
complex storytelling ahead gamora's
story illustrates this in volume 3 the
daughter of Thanos is not herself in
fact she's a past iteration of Gamora
from 2014's Guardians of the Galaxy
storyline transplanted several years
into the future the original Gamora died
in Avengers Infinity War at the hands of
her adopted father
everyone else who died in the past
stayed dead not her why was it the magic
Cliff I don't know the interactions
between this reset Gamora and the rest
of the Guardians are a nice testing
ground to explore how to tell meaningful
Multiverse narratives that actually
matter of course the fact that the
gamora's storyline was already teased in
Avengers end game made it something fans
were invested in watching play out as
soon as possible